مباراه تليق بنهايه كاس العالم ملعب لوسيل
في قطر تحول ساحه حرب شرسه بين فرنسا
والارجنتين قتل فيها المنتخبان حتى النفس
الاخير مباراه ممتعه تاريخيه وايضا صعبه
بعد ان تنفست الارجنت الارجنتين الصعداء
بهدفين مقابل 0 في الشوط الاول عادله
فرنسا النتيجه في الشوط الثاني بهدفين
الاول جاء من ركله جزاء والثاني بعدها
بدقيقه
في الشوطين الاضافيين سجل كل من منتخبي
منتخب الارجنتين ومنتخب فرنسا هدف لتنتهي
المباراه باشواتها الاصليه بثلاثه اهداف
لكل منتخب ركلات الجزاء كانت الحزم انتزعت
الارجنتين الفوز ولقبت بطله لكاس العالم
لهذا المونديال 2022 بعد 36 عاما على اخر
مره توجت بهذا اللقب وها هي تضيفه النجمه
الثالثه بهذا الفوز على قميصها